The Joe Rogan experience. I had Paulie
Malignaggi, he was at my gym and uh,
then he kind of knew,
he goes, wait a minute,
I just figured out who the fuck you are.
You're the guy. I know. He's freaking out.
So, so I take that
opportunity to ask him like,
I'm just asking them like
some boxing questions.
Next thing I know he's giving me a
boxing lesson. How fucking cool is that?
[inaudible] yes, it was three days
ago. He really going to do that.
Bare knuckle boxer is art. I'm curious.
Yeah, and he's taken it personally. Yeah,
but man,
you don't want to break your hands.
You don't want to get your face cut up.
Like,
cause he'd done fighting like boxing
bag. He's like, oh I noticed that.
He looked like he was in shape. He was
like, and he was given people pointers.
He's very, he looks, he seems, I listen
to him a lot on, you know, showtime stuff.
He's cerebral as hell. I mean he
knows the game. He's very smart guy.
He doesn't get hit a lot.
No,
I mean when you think about a boxer they
can talk as well as he can. Oh, I'm pose.
Articulate as he is and understand.
I mean if you watch him the way he fights,
like watch his fights with
Adrian Broner like he,
he knew how to figure out
the puzzle that's or his
hand speed and power punching
and he punches him volume.
He's always in gray showing me patterns,
like just basic things
that I was like damn,
I really want to see the actual sparring
match between him and Connor cause all
the UFC released. Is Connor cracking them?
I know it's a long one. It had to be,
there had to be some fun moments
in that. Yeah. I will also,
I think apparently Pauley got
off a plane and then he hadn't,
it wasn't even really,
he wasn't even working out that much
then they thought it was going to train
with them. Yeah. And they go, we're
going six rounds or something.
He was filming what you film
it. Yeah. That's something,
they use it as a promo. Right.
People are ruthless bro.
The idea that they weren't gonna use.
That is more ridiculous. Come on. Wait,
who are you? You don't understand how
this business works. They're promoting,
they're promoting of, he's a Brooklyn
Kid. He's a smart guy. Listen,
they're promoting a fight that is going
to generate hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue. You think that
they're going to spare your sensibilities,
they're going to spare your feelings and
not show edited versions of you getting
popped.
But my problem is so the,
I have a problem with that
all across the board because?
Because I feel like when common decency,
fair play, you know a contract and
ed sort of a contract, you enter,
I'm coming out to help you out and
what you're going to do is use me,
go fuck yourself. Like it's not believing
it's, I understand. I understand.
It's a business leave.
They paid him.
I'm sure they did and I believe he
signed paperwork over. I'm sure they did,
but that's a sneaky move. It's fucked
yet and I and I have a problem with it.
Fuck yes.
In general,
I just don't like justifying
anything because it's going
to be good promotion. I,
I'm always uneasy. You know how
people say, ah hey man, bad press.
But you're talking about him. Yeah, but
fuck off. I completely agree with you.
However,
I pulled to play devil's advocate.
If I'm Mr businessman mister money bags,
that shit just went in
one ear and out the other.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That's a video of some shit that actually
happened. You hate. The truth is if you,
if you hate the truth,
I can understand why you would want
to show them that video. Right?
But Conor did drop him with the left
hand and it's going to be a great fight.
Conor McGregor versus Floyd Mayweather
and ironically it might've been good for
Pauli in terms of it creating
this fight with art traits.
You're talking about them all,
I think.
I think polyman analogies stands on his
own. Not only has a boxing announcer.
Yeah, I mean he's, he's got a real name
and he's a, he's an excellent boxer. It's,
he's probably one of the better
commentators in the game, if not the best.
Oh yeah. Very, very good.
100% him and Andre Ward,
Andre Ward from the favorite and
Roy Jones Jr for Rachel's juniors.
Outstanding at it too. Yeah, he
is just brilliant. Brilliant guy.
Brilliant guy. I just watching him
like figure out Kovalev too. Right?
Especially in the second
fight. Unbelievable. Yeah.
In fact that, you know,
he dropped Covello with
a body shot and you know,
Coppola so that the didn't give him a
chance and that they just stopped the
fight, but it didn't look
like he wanted to keep going.
I felt like that way with Amir Khan, like
if people are like, oh listen to them,
come here, con has nothing
approved. He has an amazing record.
He's fighting a genius in
Crawford and probably in,
there's no shame in this. He
was supposed to fight, um,
Kell Brooks and he kind of went,
you know what, this guy is. He,
he's time is on his side and he's going
to, he's kind of figured this out.
He's bigger and he's going to kidnap.
He's going to hit me
and maybe hurt me here.
I don't feel like doing this anymore.
If that was the case,
I forgive him for everything.
It's like I thought it was
a smart decision to find
her and maybe he was really
hard. He's killed the kettle.
I'm not saying he's not,
but the Kell Brook fight would have
actually gotten Amir Khan more money.
It was a actually wanting to test
himself and he decided to take the fight
against Crawford's real fighter.
If Crawford's not the best pound for
pound fighter on earth. He's number two.
He's one or two. I want to see
him. What else? Or I'll spends,
well him Earl Spencer is fantastic too,
but I think the argument of pound
for pound is Loma Chanko in him.
Does the argument, you mean two guys
were number one? Yeah. I'm like,
who do you think is number
one? I mean, I think spreads.
You're talking about Crawford,
Crawford.
I don't know if they'll
follow them in Toronto.
I don't think Crawford's
fought enough competition.
Like when he fights Earl Spence and the,
I think that Lowman Chenko has probably
had more fights and you can really get
into this conversation cause he hasn't
everybody but he said as had he won the
world title would like four
fights. I, yeah, how many fights?
It was like something
ridiculous like that.
I mean he fought a world class
fighters first time out the,
when I saw him fight a Jorge, um, what
was that amazing Mexican fighter? Uh,
or some are like that.
Who is the guy who follows record here
is 13 and one in Crawford's 35 now. Yeah.
Wow. Big Difference. But, but boxing
is tricky that way. Right. So what's,
what's the level of competition
as they bring you up slow? Well,
the difference is Loma Chanko had
an extensive amateur background
internationally, but soda, Crawford,
Crawford had a great amateur
background to look Crawford.
The differences Crawford's way bigger.
That's the difference.
If there were the same size,
it'd be really interesting
to see what would happen.
But Crawford's a lot bigger than
him. He would. Yeah. I mean,
it's not a good fine now it's just,
I still watch him take rig and Dow and
all these amazing fighters were gone.
Dio [inaudible] I thought it was
Reagan now. I don't think so.
I think that's it in French and he gained
do Rigondeaux if he game Gumdale um,
but yeah, he did. He just manels
people. His footwork is unparalleled.
But Terrence Crawford men,
first of all,
he's probably the best switch
hitter ever next to Marvin Hagler.
He might be better. Yeah.
I mean it's hard to say.
Maybe he can find you a game plan
for that. I do so good orthodox then.
So good south paw, but to watch
Linaris that's it Jorge, that nurse,
I think it's sick fighter and to watch
him, he knocked Lemon Chenko down.
But then again, like this guy
figures you out. He just, he goes,
I know what you're doing now and then
you're done. We'll sodas. Crawford. Yeah,
I mean the the best. I mean that was
an interest in sylvan is prime to,
he would just figure out
your timing. Yeah. Figure out
what you do, how you enter,
where the gaps are, where the holes
are. Okay, I see a key to the castle.
Let's rock. Right? And then
somewhere around the end of
the first round Anderson,
we start switching stances on you and
fucking doing some Bruce Lee moves.
And the next thing you know, he's got his
foot in your face. Yeah, that's right.
It's figures you out. It's exactly
right. These guys are just the, the,
a really elite of the elite fighters.
They're just the best at
solving the little riddle.
That is what your skills are.
Now, how do you solve that
riddle that is never back.
That's a different riddle because that
motherfucker's not on the outside boxing
you. And he caught her Connor
Franta while Connor for a while.
You know,
he's going to take you down.
But what it looked like Konner
for a while was isolating.
He had two hands on that wrist.
He was stopping him for a long
time from closing his, his hands.
And, and that seemed kind of effective
for awhile. I mean, good luck.
It's a long road. That's like saying, um,
you're running a marathon. Hey, you
know he beat me in the marathon,
but for the first hundred
yards I was way ahead. I know.
That's what it's like cause it
doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
It's a five round fight like okay,
keeping me from grabbing my hands for now.
Write your hands tired yet. Yeah,
how you formed. I'm taking it down.
Just going to take it down.
That guy is so relentless and the
skill level and the endurance level,
he has to pursue that
pace for five rounds.
Like I don't think I even appreciate it.
I mean I can intellectualize
it and I could describe it,
but I think when you're in there with him,
like when he fought Edson Barboza and he
had Edson Barboza up against the cage.
Come on buddy. His mind
give up. Edson has this. No,
that was against Michael Johnson antenes
as this thousand yard stare where where
he's getting mauled. It's just like
he's like breathing. He's like, Oh fuck.
Like this is, this is a different kind
of human being. Those Russians are it.
That's a different kind of human being
so tight and they grow up fighting from
the Zip. Tommy's a baby. Yes. He's
a sad that culture. They were,
they suffer a great deal. That's
the look. He's like Jesus Christ.
What the fuck did I sign up for?
Skin mauled and I love,
I love [inaudible]. It looks like his
legs. His body looks like, you know,
guys see at the pool kind of works
out maybe a little. It just doesn't,
it looks pretty fit. I don't know.
Talking, I don't know. That guy looks fit.
Barboza is really muscular.
He was jacked man.
He's just using Shope photo of cubby
like making like a most muscular poles or
something. Yeah, he's fucking pretty Jack.
He's just not though. He's just a freak.
No, not compared to a lot of dudes. Yeah,
go down there. Look at that. You know,
cause he's dude, what are you talking
about? His jacket not, you know,
he looks like a really strong grappler.
He's got, he's, we know he is,
but really look at him like shut your
mouth and it's pretty good there.
Shut your turn. You're dirty. Lie
spilling. He's got. It's pretty good.
What about that one right there? How about
that one? Cut The shit out of shadows.
Let's go. You look like that. When you,
when you were on center TRT about when
you were young and that's what you
reflect. It's basically the
same. If I was in there it would,
you would call it steroids. You
were always like that. Yeah,
I was always like that. Yeah. When
I was going to be more muscular.
Actually when I first met you
that I didn't even take vitamins.
Now you are just jacked.
I remember first time I heard mad
TV you were jacked out of your mind.
I knew it was just cause
you lifted weights.
Well that was when I was
just getting into Jujitsu.
So I really started lifting weights heavy
cause I was tired of getting mauled.
Yeah. So I really got into lifting
website. I am weak. I'm like,
yeah cause I'm used to striking.
Striking is so different than grandpa
and different in terms of the demands on
your muscles and your
fatigue. Yeah, it's soap,
but it works the other way too because I
remember I had done any striking at all
and like a year, like I had done
none, zero just Jujitsu. And then, um,
my friend Jamie and I started
doing, um, Jamie, um, is a, um,
a trainer and we were doing
this a training session
and he had me hit mits too.
And like just hitting myths for like
a couple of minutes. I was gassed out.
I was like, how is this possible? I roll
all the time. I'm in good shape right now.
That way when we get guys
who are triathlon leads or
whatever, they come in and,
uh, Wayne McCullough shout out
to the great way. Mcculloch
my trainer, I love, um,
I love that guy. He's the best. I fucking,
that's one of my favorite
people in the world.
Like whenever I see them all is right
in the world and he's just a humble man,
silver medalist in the Olympics world
champion and nobody asks them questions in
the gym.
It's like he that you had this gold mine,
this guy here who's food beat Morales,
who fought Prince Naseem to the
distance and nobody knows it.
And he never tells anybody. And I'll see
these guys hitting. And I'm like, wait,
why don't you tell them? And he
goes, they don't ask me. I don't,
I don't bother them. He's just
the most humble dude. We're like,
it drives me fucking nuts, but launch.
But anyway, we'll get like triathletes,
people who are in really good shape.
But if you,
if you're sparring and you're afraid
to get hit, you stop breathing.
And so in three minutes, in two minutes,
I don't care how good a shape you're in,
the minute you get punched once you're
like, yeah, it took me literally,
it probably took me three years
to get over that in a way.
Cause I have no confidence
as a boxer and I shouldn't.
Okay.